oggi vorrei condividere con voi un idea
un'idea che forse all'inizio vi potrà
sembrare contro intuitiva e l'idea è
questa io penso che ci troviamo in un
momento di grande trasformazione sociale
economica in questi momenti nei momenti
delle discontinuità si creano
dell'opportunità e oggi noi abbiamo
l'opportunità di disegnare il futuro
come lo vogliamo ma per fare questo per
cambiare per sbloccare il nostro futuro
abbiamo prima bisogno di tornare a un
concetto passato ovvero al modello delle
comunità se ci pensate bene l'umanità
sta rincorrendo un sogno antico ovvero
quello di massimizzare sia le
opportunità dei singoli individui sia la
possibilità di lavorare assieme di
collaborare per un obiettivo comune e
quindi oggi vi parlerò di un nuovo
modello di comunità una comunità che è
diversa dal concetto passato non solo e
non tanto per la tecnologia che ci
unisce che ci permette di aggregare
comunità più ampie più diverse disperse
ma quello che fa veramente la differenza
e l'idea di riunire individui che
lavorano che collaborano per un bene
comune un bene la cui ricaduta possa
andare al di fuori del perimetro della
comunità stessa
per spiegarvi meglio quello che ho in
mente vi racconterò due storie sono due
storie due episodi della mia vita che ho
vissuto quasi in contemporanea sono due
storie di reti la prima storia questa è
a che fare con mio passato professionale
io per molti anni ho lavorato nella
società di consulenza e negli ultimi
anni il mio il mio lavoro è stato quello
di creare di gestire una rete di persone
di esperti in tutto il mondo che si
occupava di uno stesso tema dello stesso
settore
dovevamo mettere a fattor comune le
nostre conoscenze e le nostre competenze
le nostre idee
i progetti che avevamo fatto nel bene o
nel male e metterli a servizio di tutto
il gruppo per essere collettivamente più
smart più veloce più efficaci nel dare
risposte ai nostri clienti
io ero al centro della rete avevamo
tutto quello che ci serviva avevamo le
migliori persone avevamo le migliori
tecnologie che ci tenevano connessi ma
devo dirvi che ogni singolo giorno di
quel lavoro per me è stato faticosissimo
perché giornalmente dovevi pregare
intermediare intercedere per fare in
modo che quelle informazioni fossero
effettivamente condivise la condivisione
arrivava sempre troppo tardi troppo poco
troppo parziale troppo poco autentica
perché perché in realtà ognuno di noi
implicitamente era convinto di riuscire
a fare bene il proprio mestiere da solo
non pensavamo di avere bisogno degli
altri
e tutto questo non funzionava quindi
cosa eravamo eravamo una rete in realtà
eravamo degli atomi collegati fra di noi
solo artificialmente la seconda storia
che vi voglio raccontare la storia di
un'altra rete
una rete che la rete di valore di con
cui io ho iniziato a collaborare qualche
anno fa dando una mano a sviluppare
alcune attività
lì dentro ho trovato uomini e donne che
hanno messo a disposizione un po del
loro tempo delle proprie competenze
proprie risorse per un obiettivo comune
che era quello di parla di portare
parole come dei versetti e inclusione
nel linguaggio comune delle nostre vite
delle nostre aziende delle nostre
società
lì dentro trovato compagni di viaggio
che non mi ero scelta diversi da me
spesso anche in disaccordo con me in
competizione a volte ma non importava
perché avevamo un obiettivo comune che
era al di là di noi stessi di quello che
avremmo potuto raggiungere il giorno
successivo
dentro ho trovato manager top manager
molto impegnati che volontariamente
hanno speso un po del loro tempo per
chiamarmi per offrirmi un caffè per
chiedermi hai bisogno come posso
aiutarti puoi scambiare due chiacchiere
ho trovato colleghi in competizione fra
di loro che gioivano dei successi altrui
ho trovato amiche che mi portavano a
scalare una montagna a vincere le mie
paure a fare un qualcosa che altrimenti
da sola non avrei mai fatto
qual è la differenza non eravamo più
degli atomi quella era una rete era un
vero e proprio organismo vivente che è
cresciuto si è trasformato nel tempo e
dato origine ad altre reti ad altre reti
con altri e diversi obiettivi sfidanti e
quindi per spiegarvi la differenza tra
queste due storie vorrei ricorrere a un
immagine un'immagine sempre semplice
sono dei silos sono il sito sono dei
contenitori che vengono riempiti in
maniera completamente autonomo di
contenuto di oggetti di materiale che
viene completamente tenuto isolato
dall'esterno per paura di contaminazione
per paura di dispersione ecco io penso
che nella nostra società industriale noi
siamo un po abituati a pensarci a
vederci come dei silos ovvero ciascuno
di noi pensa a se stesso come un
contenitore da riempire di successi di
esperienze di conoscenza di contatti di
di ricchezza in un'ottica di
massimizzazione individuale
allora se noi ci vediamo come dei silos
l'approccio alle reti e network non può
che essere di tipo utilità rischio se
voi pensate all'accezione comune della
parola networking
cosa vi viene in mente a me vengono in
mente questi aperitivi dove le persone
vanno con l'obiettivo di distribuire o
di raccogliere il maggior numero di
biglietti da visita
la rete network ci serve per raggiungere
un punto che altrimenti da solo non
saremmo riusciti a raggiungere
ma se noi proviamo a rovesciare questo
concetto a non vederci più come dei
silos
ecco che la rete il network diventa un
organismo vivente diventa un luogo dove
il paradigma avere e poi dare si
trasforma in dare e poi avere il network
diventa una comunità una community
quando tutte queste persone si muovono
per raggiungere un obiettivo che è un
obiettivo più grande di lo stessi più di
lungo termine più complesso quella è una
community nelle community prima si pensa
cosa si può dare e poi che cosa si può
ricevere non so pensate al vostro
quartiere pensate al buon vicinato prima
pensate a come rendere la facciata della
vostra casa bella di come bellina con
dei fiori pensate a non parcheggiare le
auto sul marciapiede
pensate di offrire una fetta di torta
che avete fatto la domenica mattina al
vostro vicino di casa e poi sperate che
tutto questo torno indietro per fare
delle community però e questo è la cosa
più complessa ma la grande opportunità
che abbiamo oggi ci servono nuove
alleanze alleanze per unire per
collegare elementi che sono diversi che
sono più dispersi che sono più
complementari in termini di conoscenze
di background di competenze
cosa c'entra tutto questo con il nostro
futuro come facciamo a sbloccare il
futuro allora ognuno di noi deve fare la
sua parte
vi dico la mia io ho scelto di lasciare
ai nostri figli ai vostri e miei un
mondo più bello dove bellezza non è un
concetto solo estetico ma e bellezza
nelle relazioni umane anche sul posto di
lavoro e bellezza nella qualità della
vita e bellezza nella qualità dei
servizi di cui ognuno di noi ogni giorno
ha bisogno
ho scelto di lasciare loro un futuro in
cui non dovranno più scegliere se
rinunciare al proprio lavoro o rimanere
a casa per curare dei figli degli
anziani malati dei familiari disabili la
mia eredità
vorrei che fosse quello di lasciare loro
organizzazioni dove loro dove saranno
valutate per il loro talento e non per
il numero di ore che passano davanti
alla scrivania o in una riunione
vorrei che ogni volta che entreranno in
un ospedale in una scuola di un ufficio
pubblico una casa di riposo potessero
essere accolte da persone col sorriso
con la professionalità e la dignità di
chi sa di fare un lavoro importante e
fondamentale per la società
questa è la mia missione e non sono sola
ho cercato e stiamo costruendo una nuova
alleanza tra chi come me alla stessa
idea alla stessa missione e guardate
un'alleanza molto strana è un'alleanza
fatta di persone di aziende start up e
multinazionali li profit e non profit di
sindacalisti associazioni imprenditori
un'alleanza molto diversa ma insieme
collettivamente siamo molto ricchi
abbiamo spazi abbiamo luoghi abbiamo
progetti abbiamo idee abbiamo risorse
mezzi e competenze e tutti noi siamo
disposti a mettere da parte i no
linguaggio le nostre prerogative
individuali per questo obiettivo comune
e guardate che gli effetti di questa
cosa si vedono li vedono anche quei
manager che sono abituati a guardare
solo ai numeri al conto economico di
breve termine se ne accorgono
quando nei corridoi vengono fermati da
qualcuno che li ringrazia e li ringrazio
perché fra un po il 5 giugno voi sapete
5 giugno che date è l'ultimo giorno di
scuola è il giorno in cui si aprono
queste 15 lunghe settimane in cui i
genitori che lavorano si chiedono come
possono fare da può dire i propri figli
e allora ti ringraziano perché tu gli ha
organizzato un servizio ti sei preso
cura di questo gli ha evitato la briga
di andare a cercare capire come fare
dove andare come accompagnarli oppure ti
ringraziano perché a casa hanno un
familiare con una malattia cronica e non
sanno come occuparsi e tu gli hai
orientati gli hai dato delle
informazioni gli hai detto quali sono le
possibili soluzioni da chi possono
andare quali sono delle strutture
affidabili e qui quello che hai fatto
risparmiare non è solo il tempo ma è
l'ansia l'ansia di non saper fare come
risolvere un problema che più grande di
te o la paura di mettere un proprio
familiare nelle mani di qualcuno che non
sai chi sia e che non sai come fare
scegliere oppure ti ringraziano perché
magari in azienda e qualcuno che ha
perso la famiglia che ha perso la casa o
che ha un problema di dipendenza e
nessuno lo sa ma quella persona è la
stessa persona che vende i tuoi prodotti
ai tuoi clienti e la stessa persona che
guida i tuoi autobus che costruisce i
tuoi ponti che ripara i tuoi macchinari
e se quella persona un problema è quello
è un problema di tutti quanto vale tutto
questo
qual è il valore
il valore e lo si può lo si deve
quantificare nell'avere risorse più
felici più motivate più ingaggiate più
produttive nell'avere un brand
un'immagine migliore
questo lo dobbiamo e lo possiamo
quantificare ma quello che non potremo
quantificare e la bellezza che avremmo
lasciato ai nostri figli
ora questo è la mia missione
adesso dovete fare la vostra parte e
quindi adesso vi chiedo di seguirmi con
un piccolo esercizio di chiudere gli
occhi e di ascoltarmi per qualche
secondo
adesso chiedo a voi di pensare
qual è la vostra missione qual è il
vostro futuro
qual è quella piccola cosa che volete
lasciare in eredità alle generazioni che
ci seguano pensate sicuramente avete
qualcosa in mente un libro che avrete
sempre avreste sempre voluto scrivere
una piazzetta sotto casa vostra che
avreste sempre voluto vedere più verde
una casa in riva al mare qualsiasi cosa
sicuramente ce l'avete qualcosa di più
grande
adesso quando l'avete individuata
provate a pensare se ne avete mai
parlato con qualcuno avete mai detto io
questo sogno io vorrei realizzarlo
provate a farlo provate a pensare a chi
andreste a dirlo ma cercate degli
alleati che non siano i vostri amici
vostri conoscenti i vostri colleghi
cercateli lontano da voi tra chi parla
lingue diverse si usa schemi diverse
perché la giu sicuramente c'è qualcuno
che vi può aiutare a realizzare questo
sogno
e allora pensate di incontrarli di
conoscervi di parlarvi di scambiarvi
questa idea di capire con vi potete
mettere assieme e pensate di non aver
paura
date fiducia anche se sono persone molto
diverse fra voi adesso potete riaprire
gli occhi bene se avete visto quel punto
nel futuro quel punto distante che
vorreste raggiungere
adesso la strada comunque sarà lunga
sarà complicata non sarà facile ma non
siete più soli e quel futuro sarà molto
più vicino di quanto non lo fosse un
menù
per concludere vorrei lasciarvi con un
proverbio africano che dice tex willer
to raise style
serve un intero villaggio per allevare
un bambino
io penso che servano intere comunità per
allevare il nostro futuro perché il
futuro è condiviso grazie